Irene works at St Vincent Hospital in
London England she still plans on
becoming a nun but hasn't taken her vows
yet making her a noviciate something
that Everyone likes to point out
constantly you still haven't taken your
temporary vows you haven't taken your
vows yet you haven't taken your VES now
you know how I feel every time someone
asks me to make a nto video I'm
literally doing it different cultures
handle it differently but there are
basically three steps to becoming a nun
first there's discernment that's where
you're considered a sister or a
noviciate but not yet a nun once a
sister takes her temporary vows she
becomes a nun and this kind of allows
her to test the lifestyle and if she's
successful she may make her Perpetual
vows signifying lifelong commitment